For YouTube giving week 2018 psyched ago has partnered with the brain and behavior Research Foundation
Stick around until the end of the video to see how you can help fund a better understanding of various brain and behavior disorders
including depression
Depression and mental illnesses are different for everyone with this list. We are not trying to generalize
instead we've compiled certain things individuals with depression have disclosed they struggle with
Here are eight things people with depression would like their family and friends to understand
one it's not as simple as eating healthier and
Exercising more while we really appreciate you trying to help us the underlying condition isn't always solved that easily
It still feels like your feelings are being invalidated if things aren't phrased carefully
two it's not always easy to understand why things are this way?
Depression doesn't always have a specific trigger. It just happens. It's more complicated than just feeling sad because we got a bad grade
Assumptions like this are diminishing our experiences. Sometimes there's no emotion
Sometimes there's too much it often isn't very clear why either
We'd like to understand it better ourselves. But depression can make you feel a wide variety of confusing things
three it's not your fault. There's no one single factor that causes depression. It's an illness
Certain things can contribute to it, but it's nobody's fault
For it's not that we're not trying hard enough. No one wants to have depression
Telling us that we're not trying hard enough when we are in fact, trying our hardest is dismissing our struggle and it's very hurtful
five we can't just stop out of it if it was possible to simply get over it
We would have done it a long time ago. It's not a mood that you can come out of when you're done
six we don't want to hurt others. We hate to feel like an annoyance because of our illness
We don't want to cause the people around us pain because of what we're going through
seven we feel like a burden
Reassurance might not magically solve our depression, but it can help us open up the better feelings
We need validation that were not an annoyance to be able to relax around you
eight we truly appreciate your efforts. We notice you trying to help us and we are very grateful
Reaching out to us is always a ray of light. But please remember we aren't asking you to fix us
for YouTube giving week 2018
a donate button has been enabled on this video
If you would like to support the brain and behavior Research Foundation, you may do so by pressing the donate button
Please do not feel pressured to make monetary donations as even just liking the video and sharing it to others will be great
100% of every dollar donated for research is invested in their research grants
which funds the most innovative ideas in neuroscience and psychiatry.
It helps better understand the causes and develop new ways to treat brain and behavior disorders
these illnesses include depression ADHD, anxiety, PTSD, OCD, autism, bipolar disorder, and much much more
Please check out our link below to learn more about the brain and behavior foundation
Thank you so much for watching and being a part of our lovely Psych2Go community. Thank you